Dimension it yeah it is a Fifth
Dimension it looks like we have a very
big fan in the White House aids to vice
president revealing that kamla Harris
watches the five but apparently our
criticism gets in her head and causes
quote high anxiety so kamla if you're
watching and we know you are have you
ever considered that maybe the problem
is not us voters were asked to rate
their feelings toward Harris and it's
brutal only 28% felt good about kamla
and amly 10% feel quote very positive
but kamla insists that the people love
her the people who know my work um are
incredibly
supportive understanding that the work I
do now as vice president is is the
foundation of that work is years and
years of working on issues so I feel
good about it she can't be Qui
okay Harold I gotta tell you we're going
with the black thing
again no when she says that people who
know my work are incredibly supportive
just like Joe Biden shouldn't she be
ready to say this is what I've done this
is what I've done people who know my
work are incredibly support don't waste
time tell us what you've done what has
she done well I think she's part of an
Administration look there are things I'm
not I can tick off those things and
I can I mean the economy is is
performing like it is jobs are but she's
part of this Administration now I do
think I've said many times on the show I
think it would behoove uh the president
and the vice president probably the vice
president a little bit more because this
has been a part of her portfolio to get
down to the Border uh in fact if if I
were the president and the vice
president I I would give a a lot of
consideration uh to holding a press
conference at the Border in the next few
days she go there in the evening and say
look look we're going to reverse um the
remaining Mexico policy back to where it
was before we're going to reverse the
Catch and Release policy and we're going
to ask we're asking every American she's
not doing that so are you criticizing
her for not doing it well I'm I'm giving
advice now you you already went to the
block thing can I at least say by answer
here before we get
so and then lay out and ask every
American to ask their Senator and
Congressman why they won't allow a vote
to come to the floor in the house of the
Senate on this on this border security
package I can live with people voting up
or down on it but what it's hard to live
with is when politicians sell the
American people we believe there should
be no vote on the matter we're the
Democrats who the Republicans we around
this table have said ballot access for
Dean Phillips and Robert kiny Jr I've
said it they should be on ballots and
the same is true with Congress let the
bill come to a vote don't call it Dead
on Arrival let Republicans and Democrats
go back to their voters and explain why
they voted for or why they voted against
the bill that will help make our border
more secure that's what I'd be doing if
I were Dana the LA Times says that comma
has her groove back I thought that
article was over the top and gross uh
because it's never about here look at
this amazing thing that she did she
helped like imagine if Biden had said I
want you to be on the hill every day as
a former Senator and I want you to be
helping negotiate this border bill that
didn't happen so I understand that she's
going around talking about abortion and
the maybe that works for them but the
reason that we talked about her
initially on the five and maybe when she
was watching then was we would try to
give her really good advice yes like you
were just ging I was I thought that I
gave her excellent advice it was to
totally ignored um the thing that she is
getting prosecuted for now is something
that happened when she was a prosecutor
so Prop 47 is possibly going to be
repealed it has an 89% approval for
repeal that was a bill that basically
allowed for like the retail thefts for
example um and the if they can get
enough signatures that will be on the
ballot this fall that is something that
happened when she was AG of California
that was like in that era so I'm not
exactly sure where the LA Times thought
that they would write this piece
although it was interesting for for like
once it wasn't an inside DC publication
because they've been hoodwinked too many
times with that story and all of the
makeovers that she's gone through you
know Jesse she's talking about setting
the stage for 2028 oh yeah that's
true sitting what stage the presidential
go go really very funny not if Gavin has
anything say about it judge did you ever
wish you hadn't learned
something no I wish I hadn't learned she
watch yeah because now because I have so
much Humanity I feel bad demonizing her
oh I ooze Humanity you do you oo it or
lose
it so I oo it so much that now I feel
bad for demonizing her but I will say if
she's anxious when she watches the show
the way to heal anxiety is to confront
your fears so she should one day sit
between Jesse and Janine and experience
what that's like that's the only way she
can get through this we'll help her out
go ahead I sit here three days a week
she'll be on your lap Harold that's what
he's saiding no she watches the five
because everybody watches the five we're
essentially like the Vanderpump Rules
for people who weren't dropped as
children right I I maintain that Fox
News is Bravo for people who can change
it retire does that make sense but I'll
tell you what I I I I understand the
charm of this show Camala watches the
five for obvious reasons she digs me men
come to Dana for their High School Crush
right yeah viewers come to the judge for
your noons perspective uh everyone comes
to Harold for his you know gentle and
reasoned persuasion others come to Jesse
hoping that he's dead but the majority
let's be honest they come from my animal
magnetism my unbridled masculine heat
that emanates from every pore of my body
so I don't blame her for watching and I
want her to reach out and contact me we
can get together I can help you you know
we all mean well right you know you ooze
masculinity I ooze masculinity she just
loves animals are great that that might
be it that might be this is the best
show to drink to by the way so that
could be it and she's not watching The
View which if the view were in pill form
it would be banned for what it does to
your brain yes all right right and
coming up a liberal education fail in
California Student scores plummet after
spending thousands hundreds of thousands
on woke hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else